[Musik]
ich sag mal so bei 25.000 likes kommt
das nächste eine woche irgendwas ihr
könnt ja meinen kommentar schreiben was
ich machen sollte sieht aus wie vor
gekauft was gedacht jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video
was geht ab leute ich hoffe euch geht's
gut auf jeden fall haben wir gerade ich
wollte eigentlich damit morgen anfangen
ich kann nicht pennen deswegen von
gestern also draußen ist schon dunkel
thema korruption in die ecke auf jeden
fall ja leute werden jetzt gerade schon
halb elf ich bin jetzt wieder in köln
hat und ich fühle mich im mega
beobachtet deswegen gehen wir weiter
heraus und zwar ab ich bin nämlich
gedacht hey du bist jetzt eine woche
hier am wochenende fahre ich wieder nach
hause zu meinen eltern
ich habe jetzt eigentlich jeden tag uni
und irgend etwas witziges muss ja
passieren der alltag muss ja interessant
werden und ich habe ja schon wirklich
viele experimente gemacht
viele haben ja auch immer wieder was
geschrieben alex kannst du mal eine
woche das machen ganz mal eine woche das
machen und letztens habe ich denke ich
einen vorschlag bekommen
den fand ich mehr gut warum erkläre ich
euch ja da hat mir ein mädchen
geschrieben jo alex versucht doch mal
eine woche ausschließlich babyprodukte
zu essen finde ich mega witzig aber
jetzt ist wieder leicht also vor allem
deswegen weil ich früher nie
babyprodukte gegessen habe als baby ich
mochte nichts oder ich habe es heute
wieder vergessen das schmeckt auf jeden
fall das gute ist der regatta bis 24 uhr
offen
er will ihn jetzt mal die baby abteilung
und schauen was es da so gibt
und hier haben wir ein tolles rewe
parkhaus so leute jetzt habe ich eine
kleine auswahl der ziele aus
okay leute ich habe jetzt mal so auf die
schnelle so ein paar grundnahrungsmittel
für babys eingekauft und was ich auch
mal wieder entdeckt hat sind
fruchtzwerge so geil ich habe die voll
vergessen dass die gibt so jetzt haben
wir sogar wieder licht ich muss jetzt
einfach mal ausprobieren auf die
schnelle also ich habe jetzt einfach mal
dazu gezählt als babynahrung weil ich
glaube früher habe ich die immer
gegessen aber hier drin ist auf jeden
fall ausschließlich seminaren also der
test jetzt mal eben hier soll zum
orangen ich frage mich gerade recht die
vergessen konnte so geilmann ich glaube
ich es jetzt bin ich aber auch gleich
wieder zu hause so leute ich bin mir zu
hause also wir haben jetzt ja mal kurz
werke die müsste ich eigentlich in
kirchen stellten haben wir hierher
eiswaffel ohne zucker sein wird wir
schon sehr lecker schnell das hier ist
ein smoothie multi frucht geil was ich
auch vorher noch nie gesehen habe ist
dieses rewe baby wasser keine ahnung ob
das anders als wasser schmeckt morgen
für die uni einen schönen hipp bio tee
saft wenn ich ein team mit apfel geil
habe ich hier noch zweiter teil als
stärkung zwischendurch irgendwelche
müsliriegel früchte riegel und zum
frühstück guten morgen erdbeeren april
joghurt mit ihr haben wir dann jetzt
einmal meine baby also leute ich weiß
natürlich das ganze kann ich so lange
halten
ich muss morgen mal zu irgendeinem
speziellen baby geschäfte so gibt es ja
was eigentlich
eigentlich müsste ich das mal kurz
aufmachen und riechen aber ich glaube
das spare ich mir für morgen früher
natürlich eine gute nacht wir sehen und
hat eigentlich könnte ihm gemacht ja
leute was geht ab guten morgen köln hat
auch gestanden habe geduscht das muss
ich gleich zur uni ich richtige morgens
meistens nicht viel deswegen
kombiniert mit guten morgen herr werden
auch verlogen ist wieder soll wird echt
lecker sein und dazu gibt es noch nicht
und ja ich hoffe jetzt echt mal das was
gut schmeckt weil sonst haben wir ein
echtes problem ich habe nämlich nicht
viel anderes also gut das schmeckt auf
jeden fall sehr gesund auf jeden fall
auch lecker
ich glaube das ist gerade mein gesundes
frühstück seit 18 jahren
so lernt man dies muss den kühlschrank
stellen sollte macht ihr einfach mal
leute auf jeden fall jetzt sofort zur
uni steht da ist hier hat meine
mitbewohner mal wieder nicht aufgeräumt
war schneller als ich jetzt sagen wir
nehmen hier einmal den bio tee saft
joghurt kirsch banane auch lecker und
vielleicht noch die apfel raisdorf ich
hoffe ich hoffe das ist erstmal genug
das habe ich hier noch alter geht es
nunmehr so leute was geht
wir haben das schon ein paar stunden
später ich bin mittlerweile wieder zu
hause
ich hatte halt heute von 12 uhr bis 16
unglaublich uni ich hätte auch folgen in
der uni so ein bisschen was gefilmt aber
das ist immer so schwer dann irgendwie
und ben anhalt weißlichen wie wenn ich
etwas film darf und so weiter ich war im
rossmann und habe hier so ein paar ja
keine ahnung dass es mehr so für abends
spaghetti bolognese sind da wurde auch
nudeln drin mehr geht ja gar nicht
keine ahnung habe ich mir noch mal diese
reichen wohl weil ich fand hier echt
lecker und dann haben wir hier noch
karotten mit kartoffeln und alaska
seelachs
das mag ich eigentlich nicht habe ich
einfach nur mitgenommen weil ich mich
wohl vergriffen haben das sehe ich
gerade erst und vegetarisches menü für
die babys die vielleicht schon
entscheiden konnte nach ich werde
vegetarier und hier bin ich auch mal
gespannt krümelmonster cookies kennt ihr
das ist halt echt aus der baby abteilung
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe heute echt nicht so viel wie
gestern nachmittag habe ich schon hier
und ich hatte heute ist aber und
irgendwie so den mega wir probieren das
monster cookies wir gucken jetzt schon
fleißig fußball 10 jahren heute wollt
ihr mal krümelmonster tores probieren
wollte mal probieren probieren wenn man
sich mal die nährwerte von den ganzen
babyprodukten anschaut wesentlich besser
als deine erleben werden doch jetzt muss
ich mich auf mein kurzes menschlicher
körper
das ist das schön hallte flüge die ich
auf der straße sie schreit bootshaus der
mensch macht will der macht fotos
verbreitet ist bootshaus mensch gut hab
noch nie so leckere kekse gegessen
das schmeckt halt echt toll ich werde so
1 0 zucker drin ich glaube dieses nur
gesund ist ja leute ich muss 90 mg frühe
aufstehen war ich habe einen dreh für bb
bin ich mal gespannt ob ich da irgendwie
ein bisschen was an meine haut machen
kann
größere aussage zum abschluss aber diese
flachen nicht den ganzen tag anhält die
sind so geil ihr habt ihr für daraus
auch mal so heiß gemacht da kommt man
also einen stängel rein tun würde das
wird sich jetzt komm ich ja auf jeden
fall gab es immer so stäbchen dann kam
ich in die kühltruhe und dann hatte man
fruchtzwerge heißt weil die kommentare
das ist man doch nach oben guten morgen
leute ich sehe hat zum ersten mal die
sonne durch scheint das cool ist
wir haben jetzt sogar einen großteil der
leute ist echt so komisch
ich denke manchmal so morgens dann meine
haare sind einfach genau über die
letzten nach so krass viel mehr
gewachsen weil die sind jetzt schon
lange wieder
eigentlich habe ich schon wieder viel zu
wenig eingekauft das ist übrigens mein
bett aber juckt und ins musik nämlich
auch noch mit übrigens dass sie habe ich
auch noch gekauft alete schokopudding ab
dem zehnten monat
ja ich bin nun schon im elften monat den
gerade auch zuerst nur dann wenn man
einmal rein reicht wenn man erste berg
aber es ist bequem
guten morgen mein schatz alles gut hast
dich vermisst und spaß ich bin seit 15
minuten unterwegs und ich bin so
gefühlten kilometer gekommen
so leute wenn sie irgend einem parkhaus
geparkt das ist so komisch guckt euch
mal diesen club band der parkt hier aber
hat einfach seinen kofferraum offen
alter ich glaube der raub geratene bank
auf so oder so was da drin ist auf jeden
fall echt komisch naja wegenetz los weiß
ich ob man das erkennen kann aber ich
bin dort schwingt so leid ich bin jetzt
fertig war auf jeden fall mega cool ich
hatte gar keine zeit irgendwas zu essen
wenn man es mittlerweile auch schon halb
zwölf oder so also es ging eigentlich
ziemlich schnell super lecker jetzt geht
es wieder zurück nach hause und mal
gucken was noch zu machen so leute wie
schneidet ihr rad mein video das ganze
kommt einer stunde online deswegen
sollte ich mich ein bisschen beeilen und
ihr solltet euch auf jeden fall
anschauen also schaut mein letztes sein
wird und dabei ist sich diese
reiswaffeln ich weiß nicht also
irgendwie kann davon so 5 am stück essen
und dann schmecken die nicht mehr was
man aber als kleines resümee mal sagen
kann also dies zeigt ist megageil ich
bin echt gut das ist schade natürlich
ist auch logisch dass es ja für babys
oder kleinkinder
ich werde davon ich sage also eine davon
ist echt viel zu wenig ich zeige euch
das auf jeden fall auch macht also das
sind halt alles so mini portionen wenn
ihr abnehmen wollen oder irgendwie auf
diät gehen wollt dann macht eine baby
diät ich bringe dafür ist bald man
angebot raus auf bbb alex die trainings
programm abnehmen mit babyprodukten
punkt kommt an der schraube
im monat und bei gemischten von aber ich
denke ich es wird recht klappen ich hab
gerade mal kurz ein bisschen was an
meine kamera einstellung geändert findet
ihr das bild jetzt besser schreibt mir
das mal bitte in die kommentare wer voll
wichtig leute ich hab gerade einfach so
ein faires paket bekommen und ich wusste
gar nicht mehr dass ich überhaupt ein
paket bekomme und dann habe ich auch
noch einen pulli bekommen
dort gehen raus an harrys closing und
schuhe socken schuhe und hier sieht es
aus wie bei hempels weiter schaut euch
mal was hier noch alles drin ist dann
kann man es freut mich wollt wie ich
danke ich bin weg juni alles klappt auf
jeden fall habe ich jetzt um einen
wichtigen termin was die zukunft meiner
business karriere angeht herrscht
business termin und mir fällt häufig
aber noch zwölf mal seinen akku scheiße
nur eigentlich sollte ich vorher warum
ist die kamera tief und sagen eigentlich
sollte ich wollte mal was essen also ich
hab eben also ein bisschen
durchgerechnet ich habe echt heute und
gestern viel zu wenig gegessen nur das
ist so schnell etwas passendes zu finden
vielleicht mache ich einfach mal eine
pause und können
[Musik]
so etwas geht ab guten morgen
wären wir jetzt gerade damit überhaupt
das wort glaub ich hab gestern noch ein
bisschen eingekauft und zwar habe ich
die zwei von diesen teilen geholt
mahlzeit zum trinken die sind echt cool
was ich später mal zeigen machte nicht
meine wäsche gerade tun das einfach nur
3 und jetzt habe ich bis und jetzt habe
ich bis 17.55 uni so leute was genau
siehst du machst du das machst machst du
dich gerade mein getränk lustig was ich
war heute wieder live unterwegs und ich
hab's immer noch nicht hinbekommen auch
zu nehmen und euch getränken das
schmeckt das schmeckt echt gut ich habe
schon drei getrunken weil ich kann sagen
das ist das einzige was wirklich so als
da merkt man dass es halt sättigt und
der rest so 0 das ist alles viel zu
wenig und zwar ist es ganz lustig da
gibt es verschiedene sorten das ist
jetzt vanille
das gibt es aber auch zu mir du musst
gar nicht mit aber wahrscheinlich den
ist aufgeklärt
ich stehe doch drauf und zwar ist das
eine mahlzeit viel trinken ab zehn
monaten also wenn ihr mal langeweile hat
holt euch mal das schmeckt echt gut
sondern wir haben es mittlerweile schon
freitag weist übrigens soll jetzt mache
ich bin gerade bei marx und beim roggen
mal ich weiß du diese kalorien zählen
und zwar habe ich mir folgende kennt ihr
eine pizza natürlich was jetzt eine
woche durch oder viel besser zweimal
besser und zwar habe ich bin nicht mal
zum supermarkt gelaufen und habe mir mal
die aktuelle umgeschaut wegen der
probleme in das ist echt gut wie gar
nicht aber es gibt sachen davon ich hab
halt vieles ausprobiert ich aber schon
andere dinge gegessen aber mit schmeckt
der welt ich habe schon wieder anderen
wegen einer da war ich guck mal ich habe
jetzt nicht ausschließlich nur babynamen
ersten mal das geht nicht weil das sind
alles so billig portion bewusst dass
auch nicht sagt oder ist sogar und wenn
du denn deine eltern essen machen sagst
du weißt schon in mainburg
deswegen hat also ich habe auch schon
normales essen beim markt wir fahren
jetzt zurück zu mir nach hause zu meinen
eltern bei monster ist kirmes
so leute schon gesagt ich weiß gerade
nach hause zu meinen eltern
hey guck mal das leuchtet viel orange
auf der kammer bisher
das sollte sich einfach mehr als die
hälfte auf jeden fall sind wir hier
gerade vor dem staub und zeit und ich
habe mich glaube ich hier von schon
banane und erdbeere zeigt jetzt ist die
jugendkirche davon habe ich auch schon
das ist das schmeckt halt echt mega
gesund aber mittlerweile
ich habe davon bestimmt schon so acht
stück gegessen und das kann man auf
jeden fall also leute was geht ab ich
bin gerade in dem badezimmer auf meinen
eltern das cool ist klar ich sehe mich
soweit der kamerad im spiegel weil die
kamera hat keinen klub bildschirm also
ich kann mich nicht hier hinsehen aber
kann ja genau sehen ob ich gut aussehe
oder nicht und ich sehe nicht gut aus
welchem sie erstmal wieder haben
20 kunden fertig so wie sie noch ein
bisschen nach immer so leicht und zwar
geht es jetzt ganz kurz noch einkaufen
ich muss nämlich noch ein paar sachen
kaufen die ich euch gerne noch zeigen
möchte die gut schmecken die ich aber
glaube ich noch nicht auf der kamera
aufgenommen habe während ich sie
probiert habe das ist übrigens meine
mama aber die mache ich nur mit maske
drauf will zuerst sagen okay besser
nicht top ja bis jetzt habe ich nur
schon länger nicht mehr gehabt
das wetter ist heute übrigens echt geil
alter herzlich willkommen beim
supermarkt meines vertrauens
es hat folge passt zum beat
[Musik]
die das auf jeden fall die größte band
die ich hier gesehen habe so weit ich
weiß doch kurz einkaufen es gibt ja noch
so ein paar sachen die ich einfach mal
kurz zeigen wollte
ich hoffe jetzt ich gerade an dass hier
habe ich einmal körperlich fußball denn
auch das hier ist mega lecker spaghetti
bolognese das klima ist dennoch ich bin
nicht sohn nicht aber ich glaube ja auch
schon weg sagt die schmecken auch echt
lecker man muss nur leider sagen da
fehlt ein bisschen zucker aber ich weiß
mehr zu helfen
[Musik]
also wenn ich ein bisschen zucker
abschmecken
das ist das gleiche und schokocreme das
schmeckt auch okay also dass hier habe
ich glaub ich auch schon mal zeigt hier
habe ich mich leider wieder vergriffen
da wollte ich gar nicht mit karotten
nehmen aber das schmeckt glauben jetzt
hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal
drinnen ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo ich
mutter mit angefangen habe das ist nicht
gut das war etwas anderes was ich schon
getroffen gehabt diese gemüse lasagne
hatte ich noch nicht probiert das wollte
ich jetzt gleich gleich noch mal schluss
machen und diese hier könnt ihr ja auch
schon ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das
spiel noch klein wir haben ja morgen
schon sonntag na ja das gute ist auch
richtig zubereitung weil ich mein man
nicht einfach wasser erwerb dass ein
bisschen mut aus 34 minuten dabei und
schmeckt gut sooo leute das ganze ist
jetzt fertig muss offen und ehrlich
sagen es sieht für das augen jetzt nicht
sooo lecker aus sieht aus wie vorgekaute
nur was ich auch sagen muss wenn man das
ganze probiert es schmeckt echt gut
ich bin jetzt zwar nicht so der größten
utl fällen natürlich habe ich auch schon
leckere spaghetti oder nächste gessen
aber wenn man die jetzt mal vergleich
mit anderen fertig spaghetti bolognese
dann wird echt sagen wollt euch die
nachteile hätte nur um so wirklich satt
zu werden
also ich muss jetzt mindestens noch
einen punkt er ist immer nicht sogar
zwei da habe ich mich auch schon gefühlt
weil ich ein wetter schöner sonntag
leute ich hab mir mal kurz gedacht ich
geh jetzt mal raus um das ende zu machen
nein das ist mir zu hey leute also wir
haben jetzt sonntag ich habe montag
ich habe ja montag mit dem ganzen
angefangen und ich habe jetzt glaube ich
in sieben tagen einiges ausprobiert
natürlich ich habe es jetzt auch schon
öfter gesagt ich hab es nicht
ausschließlich nur babynahrung gegessen
da hätte ich mich noch ein bisschen auf
mich gefühlt aber ich habe auf jeden
fall sehr sehr viel ausprobiert und
jeden tag doch schon einiges an
babynahrung gegessen spaghetti zum
beispiel sind super lecker die joghurts
superlecker die smoothies sind auch
super lecker und die sind auch glaube
ich ziemlich gesund ist halt komplett
alles ohne zucker also vielleicht nur
mal als tipp kann man auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren so ich habe mal nachgeguckt
das letzte video eine woche macdonald
war das hat schon 40.000 likes und ich
glaube schon 800.000 jus oder so keine
ahnung ich würd mal sagen mal schauen
was man mit diesem video schaffen ich
sag mal so bei 25.000 likes kommt das
nächste eine woche irgendwas ihr könnt
ja meinen kommentar schreiben was ich
machen soll es macht auf jeden fall
immer unfassbar viel spaß so die ganze
woche zu verfilmen was alles passiert
und alles halt um so ein thema gestrickt
sag ich mal ich muss jetzt das video
schneiden das soll heute noch online
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder ich
würde sagen haut rein daumen nach oben
abdrehen instagram